[Music]
say
[__]
[Music]
podcast something about Ley what's going
on you [__] um oh man I'm you
ever have one of those days where it's
like is the universe trying to tell me
to go back to bed because I will
I will um M she had a rough day
yesterday right and I figured out I
figured out
broads all right I've learned how to
respect these
[__] no I've actually figured
out you know how to be in a relationship
I just get it now it's like you're with
somebody that agreed to spend their life
with you and if you're walking around
being a grumpy [__] not only are you
wasting your life you're wasting their
life too
so check in on her right check it in on
you and um she had a bad night's sleep
and my my son kept coming in and
everything so I just said hey you know
why don't you go sleep in my office
tonight I'll get the kids ready yada
yada yada right and one of my and she's
like you do that for me I said
absolutely she gave me a sweet kissed
right on the cheek told me she loved me
you know and she woke up the next day
just glowing right as rain great
move been humming songs around the house
fantastic right me on the other hand uh
I sat there and watched [__]
Instagram videos I watched a guy on
YouTube teach me how to play uh what do
you do for money honey ACDC and I was
just watching it going I'll remember how
to do
this I don't know what the [__] I ended
up stopping on but by then it was like I
swear to God like 2:30 in the morning I
was like why did I just [__] do that
of course my son shows up at like 4:00
in the morning I think maybe I got to
bed at
1:30 and
uh I just been [__] I don't know went
downstairs I made him waffles for got
the whole
thing you know my wife's like singing a
song and I'm just sitting there like
[__] blur eyed right and uh so I go
to one of my favorite coffee joints
after I drop the kids off at
school and I get my wife what she likes
you know her decaf
latte and I just go in there and I go
let me uh let me get a cata right so I
get that [__]
thing I go to get in my car and there's
somebody in the [__] crosswalk and
there's this impatient [__] in a van and
the second the person gets out of the
crosswalk I'm getting into my car with
two coffees and I just hear the van
going coming up the street and I'm like
you know I like my left leg and arm
so in a haste I go to reach and close my
door with my coffee in my hand and it
[__] falls to the
ground I closed the door and you know
what the van was actually he had changed
lanes cuz he saw my car I didn't even
need to do it and I spilled my
coffee and it was one of those things it
was just so sad I was so looking forward
to it that I I didn't even get upset and
I was actually kind of thinking like
dropping your coffee as an adult is the
that's the adult equivalent of like the
ice cream falling off the cone as a
kid and I was just like H you know I
want to make sure her coffee is still
the right temperature I'll bring it home
and I'll just make a [__] coffee so
made myself a little
cappuccino sat on the back porch did a
little bit of
FR and uh now I'm now I'm talking to you
and when I was on Instagram again CU I
am I have an espresso too I just go back
to back [__] bang bang just I used to
drink beer in a
shot and uh I see Maron Lynch one of the
greatest running backs of all time I
would say the most Unstoppable guy since
Earl
Campbell and uh talking to Shannon sharp
Hall of Famer right and they're talking
about the end of that Seattle Seahawks
Patriots
game and uh you got to see the
clip and it's amazing and everything
that they say and everything I I
definitely agree with it but I I got to
be honest with you and you're going to
say this is because I'm a [__] Pats
fan but like Bill bich is like and I'm
just going to say this because this
[__] [__] right now acting like
Tom Brady is the reason why we won all
those super bowls and belich isn't
[__] without him it's like that [__]
guy first of all bich drafted him and
then built a team around him for 20
straight [__] years and just kept
with second round [__] draft
picks and did what he did and not to
mention Tom would have only won five
with us if it wasn't for the brilliant
coaching of Bill bich in that Seattle
game having the Patriots prepared for
that play every mouth breather in the
world is like why did I give it a
[__] base mod every everybody knew
that he was going to get the
ball right so Pete Carol I don't know
how many times I got to break this down
he goes I'll call this play because
everybody's thinking it's marshan Lin I
still have another down to give it to
him he's [__] beast mode I like my
chances there but this play here the
whole season has either been a touchdown
or incomplete it's 100% safe the
analytics said it was safe but he ran
into a guy named Bill bich who actually
had his team prepared for it and here's
a [__] name that never comes up in
that moment the hero of the moment
Malcolm Butler that name is being lost
to history because everybody's so busy
talking about like how [__] Pete
Caroll [__] up in that moment and
nobody's looking at it like wow the
genius of Bill bich it's kind of like
the uh 18-1 Patriots it's not that the
Giants had the greatest [__] playoff
run that I've seen maybe
ever it's not that Eli arrived and
became the Superstar if you know the
[__] New York media State still game
[__] that wasn't the story it wasn't
that the Giants had this unbelievable
run it was that the Patriots
lost so um this segment is called
shining the light on what the [__] you
should be looking at if you understand
football
um bill bellich is such a [__] genius
that he made P Carroll look like the
dumbest [__] coach of all time and P
Carroll isn't he's a Hall of Fame
[__] coach all right and it's very
easy after something doesn't [__]
work out to be like well why the [__]
didn't you just do this you know it's
like all those [__] [__] when uh
that that submersible went under all
these [__] [__] like you wouldn't
catch me [__] doing that [__] you
talking about look at some of the rid
you go on at Six
Flags [__] bungee cord to your
goddamn leg and you know and all of
these stupid [__] roller coasters
that they run
24/7 and occasionally spray some WD 40
on you'll [__] get on one of those
you just don't have a
boat oh my God I just spilled that
[__] coffee what is going on with me
today right on the couch she going to
[__] kill me dab at it dab at
it Jesus Christ this is what they always
say dab at it don't [__] wipe it dab
it [__] dab at
it hand towel I'm sure this will work
good something that's designed to dry
off your hands it's now being used to
clean up a
mess I spilled a cup of coffee yesterday
walking up a flight of stairs I didn't
lift my leg high enough so I caught my
toes on the next stair and I went did
one of those right what'd you do Bill I
went [__] dump my goddamn
coffee I think this is the universe
saying Bill you're drinking too much
coffee and you need to stop do you know
what I haven't hit bottom yet so I'm
going to keep going
um anyway
so I don't I don't know I'm just Malcolm
Butler everybody just you know just have
the
decency because he knew the play was
coming not only did he he didn't just
jump in and knock it down he jumped the
[__]
route and intercepted the
ball because Bill bich had him [__]
prepared remember Tom Brady jumping up
and down like a little school kid he
thought he had the [__] game was lost
people forget
that cuz he went down to titty town and
[__] W1 with Tampa Bay right [__]
the Hooters capital of the world he went
down there and [__] won another one
then all these just the level of [__]
idiots who watch football all the time
and all they do is watch the
ball and
like he won six there and then he left
and then he won one and bill bich hasn't
won one since so therefore all six of
those are the
[__] yeah it wasn't [__] belich it
wasn't Teddy brusi it wasn't all these
[__] guys that we had it wasn't all
of these other guys it was just Tom
Brady he was blocking he was
running what about when they threw the
[__] ball to Tom Brady was wide open
against the Eagles and he dropped it you
remember
that my favorite part of that Super Bowl
was then the Eagles run the same play in
it's successful then Collinsworth is
like I've never
[Music]
seen a [__] now I got a phone call I got
a phone call sorry I had a phone call
there yeah cin was like I never seen
anything like that it's like dude you
just saw
it who about Willie
mcginness one of the greatest [__]
linebackers of all
time like how many [__] games did
that guy win what about Edelman
everybody talks about the [__]
comeback against the [__] Atlanta
Falcons what about that catch Edelman
made that no one would have had [__]
made Tom Brady did everything Bill
bellich he just sat there with this dump
up and how how did Bill Parcels do
without bill bich I am so [__] sick
of being this right all the time guys I
just can't handle the pressure anymore
of trying to educate you [__] mouth
breathing morons I'm better than all of
you
um I'm just a man who dropped his coffee
this morning and for whatever reason is
yelling about a football game that we
won 10 [__] years ago Malcolm Butler
Malcolm
Butler do your
job um anyway plowing ahead what a crazy
week in football huh what a [__] I mean
Jesus Christ my
nuts um old Billy old Billy two and two
2 and two what what week are we in I am
uh I can figure this out I am
11 was 9 and S so now I'm 11 and
N that doesn't make sense yes it does
we're five weeks in and I have
yet I have yet to have a losing week
betting against the book I've only had
one winning week three and one all
right I've gone two and two the other
four weeks
and everybody would be like you know
this is Bill Burr not Bill bellich we
have to get rid of this [__] guy and
I'm just sitting there going like hey
you know the key to a good relationship
is balance I mean if we win all the time
then people aren't going to like us and
then they're going to accuse us of of
cheating because they're too [__]
stupid that they're not smart enough to
learn how to beat us so then they have
to get on the competition committee and
[__] change the rules of the game to
tip it in their favor and then steal our
offense but that's not cheating it's not
cheating when you do that in
Indianapolis
that's Indianapolis they they grow our
corn no you know those people out there
they put their pants on one leg at a
time as they go to their Clan
meeting um all the caffine she's Kick It
In I did full Downs the other day in the
helicopter man um I was [__] crushing
it the only thing I have to do is at the
very end is ADD left pedal that's what I
have to do cuz if I was ever to land on
the grass there that was just a little
cockeye cuz you want to look right down
at your feet like that's the ground
that's the ground right there am I going
to make it but you don't you look long
like a [__] stud like I know I'm
landing this [__] I got to make sure I'm
straight because once somebody fixes
this thing I'm flying it over that
[__] Horizon that's how you're
supposed to be I like Billy caffeine
Billy caffeine has
confidence Billy caffeine talks
[__] Billy am Billy am's looking at the
ground his [__] shoulders are slumped
pajamas are [__] cockeyed you know
why I finally fig did I talk about this
I finally figured out why as you get it
as an old man why your your ass crack is
always coming out of the back of your
pants I already talked about it's your
[__] belly pushes the pants down
below sea level right more your ass
crack starts to show like [__] Lake
meat out in Vegas and then all your sins
are [__]
exposed
that's what it is that's the analogy
it's like Lake Me Slowly drying up is
your belly you know cuz it's not only
your belly I said that on uh on Monday
that it was your
belly the third titty is what I call it
uh your third titty you can't have a
belly cuz even if your pecs are [__]
rock hard like your [__] used to be when
you woke up in the
morning um even if your pecs are rock
hard if you got that third [__] titty
it brings the other two down it's like
having a rat in the house he's talk he's
going to the feds your [__] belly
makes your two pecs look like titties
and then it's just like you know you
don't want that every woman in the world
just feeling bad for your wife going
look at that sweaty [__]
mess just trying to hammer away you know
eek out with one more [__] season on
top with the league
minimum um
anyway
uh the [__] was I I just went off in
that [__] thing there was something
else that I wanted to talk to you guys
about and I and I for the life of
me I can't remember
um oh I'm also on pins and needles
because uh you know there's something
very important about to happen in my
career and I'm not allowed to talk about
it cuz I tow the [__] company
line all right this is Bill Burr not
[__] bill
ma uh oh I know what I wanted to talk
about
um no I'm not telling the company I'm
standing with the people that's what I'm
doing right there you go Oh Billy
hero oh I was talking about Billy
am you know this [__] shuffling you
know when your your your slippers are
just you're walking down the the [__]
uh
uh the hallway down to your kids' rooms
and the way you're moving your feet you
might as well be on Cross Country Skis
by the way that's another
one all right if you're dating somebody
who can't even [__] pick their feet
up to walk down the street or across the
[__] Hall you have to get out of that
relationship because I'm going to tell
you right now that is a
metaphor there's a met they're going to
be a
drag you know like you ever go you ever
go bet the ponies remember when they
have the little carriages behind them
and you see that guy pulling back on his
horse so he wouldn't [__] win cu the
fix was in that's what they're going to
do to you that's what they're going to
do to your dreams that's what they're
going to do to something else cuz there
always has to be three examples why
can't there just be
two I love how two is like well you know
anybody can come up with two three
you're like oh [__] yeah Jesus that guy
made a [__]
point and just the sound of them
dragging those feet across the [__]
floor every morning you start
anticipating it you start waking up
earlier so you can just go down and have
a peaceful breakfast without the sound
of them dragging their goddamn loser
feet across the [__]
lenon and what happens no matter how you
know you get up early where you go you
going too no no no honey honey keep
sleeping oh go oh oh I'll make your
breakfast
and then you just find
yourself thinking murderous
thoughts and you try and you're
rewinding in your
head like how what happened to you in
your childhood that led to you marrying
a
[Laughter]
shuffler
ladies when you meet a guy all right
he's wearing a suit and all of that [__]
you know he's got his [__] little
tassels on his loafers and
stuff all right if you can you know be
sitting
down you got all those are nice shoes
let me see those you know and then
they'll [__] you know bring them up a
little bit look at the
souls you look at the souls of a man's
shoes you'll see the man's Soul you'll
see who the [__] he is if the tops look
really [__] new and the bottoms look
like he got [__] dragged by a bread
truck you don't want to be with that
person just a little dating
advice just a little da dating advice if
you are dating somebody that yawns and
doesn't cover their mouth and literally
is doing like a [__] yawn like one of
those big cats in Africa except they're
not bringing home the [__] bacon
you're going to start thinking about
having a harpoon and throwing it into
the back of their
throat and if you marry somebody that
shuffles their feet and yawns like a
[__]
cheetah like a
leopard dude you want to hear a [__]
hilarious text message that I got from a
buddy of mine back in Boston listen to
this this this is listen to this [__]
poetry uh and I'll read it in his accent
uh my personal feeling is that these
insulet Towny types are getting exposed
for their small town shenanigans
I literally wrote back that should be in
a [__]
movie I mean you could have pitched that
line to be in the [__]
departed um by the way he was talking
about a murder SL coverup that was his
take on it my personal feeling not his
feeling his personal feeling is that
these insulin Towny types are getting
exposed for their small Town Shenanigans
small town Shenanigans murdering
somebody and covering up [__]
hilarious um speaking of the [__]
departed one of the great Hollywood
combinations of all
time I mean I think I can promote
somebody else's movie right is that how
it [__] works Leonardo DiCaprio
Martin score
sey have a new movie coming out and I
will be seeing that um I'm going to see
that this weekend killers of the flower
Moon I actually started to read the book
and then realized 80 pages in that I was
too dumb to do this I also found out
that there was a movie hey the lovely
Nia come on in
sweetheart I'm doing my
podcast come here can I just read you
one thing before I hit
pause uh this is what my buddy wrote me
okay from back in Boston hi everybody on
the podcast oh it's been a while it's
been a while it's been a while because I
you know I feel like our our
interactions are on my Instagram now not
so much on the podcast oh really did you
happen to know your Instagram page look
at you just NY promo you [__]
H how don't call me a HOA I didn't call
you a HOA I called you a HOA you watch
The Sopranos you think it's funny uh
real quickly um how'd you sleep last
night it was great huh huh bill
was I had you know I was having a bit of
a rough day yesterday I didn't have
enough sleep I was traveling recently
lashing out at her husband I was a
little grumpy uh threw some things that
I did not throw things stop stop telling
you threw your words at me and I have to
tell you that that hurt more than you
actually throwing something oh God
you're the main thrower of things um
anyway you just reached for that what
was I going to say
oh oh so yes I was having I was having a
little bit of case of the grumpies you
uh and Bill said you know why don't you
sleep over the
garage and get your nine
hours it's how I treat the ladies why
don't you go sleep over the garage yeah
go sleep over the garage um yeah anyway
socast studio slout room everything yes
uh the allpurpose room um and I'm glad
that I did cuz I had a great night sleep
and I feel so get to the point your
husband is awesome this isn't about you
I thought it was no oh the point is my
husband's awesome there we go all right
you got to press pause bye everyone
bye all right I didn't even have to
[__]
stop she just whatever anyway plowing
ahead here um yes so don't
marry a [__] shoe shuffling big
yawner
all
right and then uh I got well I got to
bounce this out I got to give guys
advice the kind of woman that you should
[__] stay away from
um most of
them I mean Bang all of them but like
stay away from most of them if that
makes sense that's my dating
[Music]
advice ah when did a Playboy become a
[__] boy think they've really just
labeled everything to try to make don't
[__] listen you know all these he's
just a [__] boy yeah [__] you you ever
think that maybe he banged you and you
just weren't interesting enough to be in
a
relationship great he [__] you and he
left way less painful than him [__]
you hanging around and listening to your
boring stories and lying to you and
saying that he loves
you all right [__] boys formerly known
as Playboys are some of the most honest
people out there you know or the other
way is they get their lie out of the way
quickly it's quickly understood that
they just wanted to [__] you and who's
kidding who you wanted to [__] him he
came in there with his Blazer and he had
his scar around his [__] neck old
school Playboy he came in there you were
enamored right you were enamored and you
wanted to see what would it be like with
a guy that could bang anybody but has
decided tonight to bang me right and you
live that life and your ego gets in the
way your ego told you that you were more
interesting than any other woman out
there you were the most interesting
woman on the planet well guess what
you're not and this is the great thing
about being a woman right is even when
you lose you still got [__] I've never
met a guy that got laid and then she
didn't call back and then well what the
[__] he doesn't give a
[__] I had a good time I had a good
time I wished it continued it didn't but
at the end of the day it was a good
[__]
time women are like I thought I was
going to be able to take half your [__]
I thought I was going to have the option
to work or not like they want that and
and
Dick why listening to Beyonce and acting
like they're an independent woman I mean
that is the world that we're living in
and then when you look at other
countries around the world and you see
the way they treat their women you start
to understand
yes it was wrong to give women this many
rights people when we return we're going
to be talking about women's suffrage did
we go too far is
men did you guys ever used to listen to
the Phil Henry Show when he used to do
[__] like that and then he would he
would imitate a fake caller calling in
going like and he would just use like an
effect and he would just be going like
yeah I mean I don't think I
don't I don't think women should have
the right to vote and he would just keep
doing that until somebody finally took
the [__] bait and then he would just
argue with them as the caller and then
he would as the host try to act like he
was trying to stop them from arguing
while he would the other person on one
of the most you know all of these people
that think they know what trolling
is all right all you goddamn young
people with your whole lives ahead of
you
um I've drank I've drank so
many cups of coffee this week that I'm
surprised I didn't buy a
Vasa I mean once you drink as much
coffee as I drank this week like that
vesus should just show up and they just
hand you the bill and you're like I I
don't I don't want no just you're you're
in this life now you know and then I do
some pretentious
video you know the American who tries to
[__] act like they're European cuz
they've never really been they haven't
been there long enough to realize that
they're [__] too they start
romanticizing everything over
there um wait Billy you talking about
yourself yes I'd love to have a vesa
some douchy toothpaste color drive it
down the [__] Street you
know get hit by a Nissan Leaf walk with
the limp for the rest of my life and lie
to people that I was on a Harley these
are the things that I think about all
right let's uh let's do the reads for
this week let's do the reads baby that's
the new intro song how did you like it
was it toned deaf
enough um I'm like five [__] Moto GP
races behind and I know that Jorge
Lorenzo was that who it was Jorge
somebody is is taken over uh is in first
place in front of uh Pekka
b um and I need to get caught up I'm
going to get caught up after the
craziness of this week that I just have
to sit there and keep my [__] mouth
shut um even though it's one of the most
important things in my all right Helix
everybody Helix it's Helix sleep
everyone the Helix lineup offers 20
unique mattresses including the award W
winning Lux collection the newly
released Helix Elite collection a
mattress designed for Big and Tall
sleepers Elite collection I thought it
was going be a design for bankers and
and people that run corporations no it's
for Big and Tall sleepers all right tall
people and fat people and even a
mattress made just for kids how will you
know which Helix mattress works best for
you in your body take the Helix sleep
quiz and find your perfect mattress in
under under 2 minutes and your
personalized mattress is shipped
straight to Y DEA free of charge that's
why they offer a 100 night trial and a
10 to 15 year year warranty to try out
your new Helix mattress models with
memory I thought models were dumb oh
jeez that's a dad joke models with
memory foam layers to provide optimal
pressure relief if you sleep on your
side models with a more responsive
form foam sorry to cradle your body for
essential I want to get cradled by a
model uh essential support in stomach
and back sleeping positions plus enhance
cooling features to keep you from
overheating at night then you don't have
to crank the AC and if your spine needs
some extra TLC they got you every Helix
mattress has a hybrid design combining
individually wrapped steel coils in the
base with premium foam layers on top
it's the perfect combination of comence
of support Jesus Christ how long does it
take to describe a [__] mattress
there's like another five [__] plus
helic mattress are American made that's
right red white and blue and come with a
10 to 15E warranty depending on the
model all right that I like American mid
you could have [__] stopped
describing the
foam um don't want to take my word for
it Helix has been awarded the number one
mattress picked by GQ and Wired Magazine
it's even recommended by multiple
leading chiropractors and doctors of
sleep medicine as a go-to solution for
improving your sleep Helix is offering
20% off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com and use the code Helix
Partners 20 h e l iix p a r t n e r 20
not Partners Helix partner Helix partner
this is the their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts now all right that's the
podcast
everybody um enjoy the music and then
we'll have a bonus up episode of the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning
bucket um enjoy your weekend your [__]
let's go
[Music]
packs hey what's going on it's Bill Burr
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for uh October 19th
2015 how's it going how I yeah uh I'm on
the road I'm on the road again CH boom
choom boom boom I just can't wait to get
on the road again well you know what I
can't wait to get on the road again cuz
I'm an old man and I'm out here and I'm
cold oh God I love the Midwest but it's
right right when the [__] winter
starts this can be kind of a
[__] you know this this takes me
back to my days back in the day when I
was young and I had more freckles um and
I used to do
uh I used to do all the college Gam gigs
out here um you know my agent uh bass
schula used to always book me um they
were based out of still are based out of
Chicago and they used to just book me in
like
duth de Mo the Quad Cities Hayes
Nebraska Grand Junction
Colorado Colorado wasn't as bad cuz you
had the Rocky Mountains to look at you
could be like oh my God it looks like a
beer commercial
you know that guy who does those [__]
Ram commercials what's his name Sam
Elliot would get on there Kors
beer brood in the Rocky Mountains no it
isn't no it isn't they don't have a
factory up in the Rocky Mountains they
don't it's on the flat lands it's
probably somewhere in Denver although
the rent's probably too high I don't
know where it is where the [__] can you
[__] shuttle in illegal immigrants in
and out the back door nobody will see it
you know that's not up in there you're
not going to get illegal immigrants to
go up to a [__] Mountain all right
they're already like listen dude I
already swam across the [__] filthy
River to get in here okay I'm not
walking up a
mountain you know if you're going to
[__] exploit
me with my lab we're doing it right here
and then they go all right build a
factory around it U maybe it is up in
the mountains I have no idea I just
remember at one point I I was rafting
not rafting I was in like a little inner
tube going down the river with a bunch
of other [__] people that was the
same river oh that's right we went by
the Kors Factory I'm like this is the
[__]
Factory all those you know those Denver
hippies there were specific kind of
hippie the Denver hippie you know their
action sandles you know same sort of
look at those hippie toes kind of thing
but they also have that look like you
know they're going to go swing on a rope
and jump into a [__]
Lake those Denver hippies you know them
they're like [__] ski instructors for
their whole lives right like 50 you
still got long hair you
know [__] go out and buy one of those
squirrel suits one of those flying
squirrel suits like that type of [__]
right I think I I went from hippies into
uh I don't know what those people are
those people who jump off of
buildings with their parachute watered
up in their hand like a like a OU at a
wedding you know and then they just
throw it we except it saves their
life you
know I don't mind that those [__] do it
it just bugs me that they have to film
it you know what I
mean you know if you're awesome why
can't you just be awesome and just go do
it you know the fact that you got to
film it that really knocks it down from
me you never saw Superman with little
[__] GoPro on did you he just [__]
went out and saved people then he goes
home puts his [__] Janan GFF glasses
back on he goes back you know goes back
to the [__] uh the
newspaper dude Clark K couldn't close a
[__] piece of [__] if he never he
never banged Lois L did he I mean
granted she had a crush on a
superhero but you know you could work on
her insecurities come on Lois you're not
going to land that I'm right here let's
make a life together right give you take
off my navy blue trousers over here and
do something give me a little help can
you get the Kryptonite out of my nuts
there Loy
right these [__] [__] jumping
around on those little flying squirrel
suits it's just you know I don't
understand why you feel the need you
have to film
yourself to be a little more
Superman all right little little less uh
Colorado Rocky Mountain hippie oh
they're the worst they're the worst you
know when you go to San Francisco and
you run into a hippie it's like you
expect it you know what I mean oh yeah
that's right all the leaves are
brown and the sky is gray and the sky is
gray I have dirty feet sorry sorry
excuse me I us kind of carry it to him
um when you go to Rocky Mountains what
what do you expect do you expect you're
going to see that guy walking
around with the orange crush Barrel
around him remember that guy I think he
died the guy used to go to all the
Broncos
games you know expect you're going to
see that you're going to see some uh
Frontier kind of
ladies right you expect to see Sam
Elliott drinking a Coors Coors Light the
Silver Bullet that's what you expect to
see and then you show up and it's just
this new [__] hippie this hippie that
skis hippies don't
ski right hippies don't base
jump
it's a special kind of heat when you're
up there too in the mile high city by
the way how about how about a hand for
the Cleveland Browns this way this week
you know Finding 87 possibly 88 ways to
lose that game to the Denver Broncos
Grant the Broncos were [__] up
too unreal when [__] uh pton threw
that pick if Eli threw it it would have
been dropped you know
[__] Eli is the the I'm telling you I
don't ever want to see that guy on the
other side of the field again the
football guards love Eli
Manning unless he plays the Eagles the
Eagles always play the Giants tough
there's always that one team you know
there's always that one [__] Achilles
him but I swear to God if Eli threw that
ball you know that the linebacker went
right to him he would have been like he
would have dropped it and Eli would have
got there with his face all mushed into
into that [__] helmet and you just
look at at like Eli he looks so dumb in
a helmet he should be still wearing his
Dockers with his pads underneath it you
know but you know goddamn well Eli's
going to go down the field he's going to
throw a [__] ball somebody's going to
catch it between their helmet and their
taint it's just it's over even when he
[__] up like just [__] just it's it's
over you cannot beat the
man at some point the glass slippers got
to turn back into a pumpkin that's my
prediction this year is Eli's to throw a
pick in a big situation and for the
first time in his career somebody's
actually going to hold on to it that's
what I'm hoping anyways all right
plowing ahead here so pton throws a pick
cuz he's not Eli and the football guards
don't like pton cuz Payton has Godlike
numbers and they're intimidated by him
they look at Eli they go oh look at this
guy he's got a cold or something I don't
I don't what's he's got the MS what's
going on with his cheeks so Payton
throws the ball [__] the Browns
intercept it they're on like they're on
the [__] on Denver's 39 yd line it's
a tie [__] game I can't remember if
it was overtime or not I had bad a bad s
signal on the bus there right and
um all right so they're they're on the
39 first and first and 10 you're on the
39 yd line football fans how long a
field goal is that huh come on do the
mat little douche do the math um you had
10 yards for the End Zone that's 49 yard
Plus 8 yards when they got to hike it 49
and8 is 57 it's a 57 y so they basically
need to get they need to get a first
down okay move the ball [__]
forward so at the very least you know
you can take a long shot at a field goal
47 yards no walk in the park but these
[__] kids can they can do it today
you know even when they're little
they're kicking virtual reality field
goals right into their flat screen TV
you've seen the videos and all of a
sudden their sneaker comes off and
breaks the TV and everybody laughs haha
he he what happened well let's throw
that [__] thing out and get another
$800 [__] TV and where does that flat
screen go why is there anybody out there
that can repair a flat screen TV when I
was a kid when you had those [__]
square TVs that were on the legs that
weighed like 900
lb way heavier than a flat FL screen
right you know it's like a [__] flat
screen's like a
uh like a Giant's [__] iPhone you
know basically relatively the weight you
know those old school [__] square
TVs you know it was like I I don't know
why they were like a
safe you couldn't move those [__]
things but still we did you moved it out
the door and somebody fixed it you came
back they give it a new
tube I don't understand why you can't
repair anything nowadays
then everybody's like oh you know oh you
broke the TV and then it ends up in the
[__] ocean right get the [__]
thing fixed you
[__] do you know my wife got our
microwave fixed I'm so excited I'm so
excited I don't even use the microwave
it a long time ago I was doing a [__]
show and one of the actors on there said
hey you know I don't I don't you know I
don't need anything out of a microwave
and I said oh really there thespian why
is that he's like well they didn't
experiment where uh they watered these
plants with water and they watered these
other plants with water that it's been
stuck in a microwave for like a minute
each day each day they'd microwave the
water and uh there was no nutrition no
nutrients left so I guess it doesn't
really cause any cancer or anything but
it just kind of nukes all your [__]
there's nothing in there you just you're
eating like space is what you're eating
you've eating something that's going to
fill up the space in your stomach is
what I'm trying to say right that make
any [__] sense I don't know I have no
idea I'm laying in a [__] bed here in
Fort Wayne Indiana what do you want from
me the creepy downtown of Fort Wayne
Indiana Jesus Christ what I didn't get
let me get back to the game here so they
[__] uh so he throws the pick and
what do they do they got three [__]
plays the very least you got to run
three plays to advance the [__] ball
first play they lose two yards now it's
a 59
y the next play they take a [__] sack
for like 10 yards now it's like a 70 y
and they [__] ran it like a [__] and
it the guy just falls
down maybe it was two runs in a sec I
can't remember what then they got to
punt the ball
away you know what I did cuz I watched
enough football in my life I shut the
[__] TV up cuz I like that's y that
that's the game it's the game right
there you had your [__] opportunity
and you blew it you know it's like that
broad at work that chick at school you
should have asked out you didn't do it
you know and here you are years later
tracking it down on [__] Facebook
look right it's
over it's [__] over Let It Go same
thing with the Browns it's [__] over
so anyways like I said I'm here in
downtown
um I'm in downtown uh Fort Wayne here
going to drive down to Cincinnati and uh
I love it out here man I mean I don't
like when all the crops are cut down it
isn't quite that time yet that's the
worst when you're out here in like
February and the crops are cut down
right and it's overcast that overcast
Sky you know CU it's so [__] flat you
can actually look look out as you're
driving down these Country Roads you see
where the overcast Guy meets the ground
and the crops are cut down dude and you
know I never
understood how a band like slip
knot came from [__] Iowa I'm like
what what what the [__] are they so
goddamn angry about yeah you're out here
milking
cows you
know making checks on farmersonly.com I
mean there's a lot lot to be happy about
out here and when I went out there in
February I was like okay I get it now I
get it there's nothing to [__] do out
here 8 7 6 6 6 five right all of a
sudden it all starts making
fence making fence making
sense
um this [__] goddamn screen saving
thing my [__]
computer 5 seconds I got to put my
password in why are they acting like I'm
so [__] important I know all you
young [__] are like well go into your
settings and you go into your [__]
settings you douche look at this I know
my [__] password is and I never get
it right the first
time oh Jesus Christ come on come
on did I forget my password this would
be [__] up this would be
embarrassing come on come on come on
come on one time one time Daddy needs a
winner all right there we go just click
on your finder and go into the settings
and hit
application
um hey how about the Patriots huh beat
the Colts great game great game Andrew
Luck's a [__] man dude the guy's a
[__] man I love watching that guy
play um he's not a whiner takes his hits
he gets back up he helps the guy up who
hit him he's just a [__] stud and um
I really realized it when I watched it
last night that it wasn't I I don't hate
the Colts
I hate Jerry uh Jerry Jones I hate Jim
ERS I hate their [__]
owner um and I hate a lot of their fans
I had fun last night in Fort Wayne I was
trying to get them to admit I go come on
you guys admit it admit it the lights
are down no one can see you admit
it you lost by 38 points all right it
wasn't because of the air pressure come
on be honest with
yourselves somebody said Tom Brady was
gay or he was a [__] or something like
that you know and
uh I just went on this whole riff about
how beautiful a man Tom Brady
was you know and how beautiful his wife
was and that deep
inside I was talking to the person in
the crowd that they
realized that
genetically they had no hope of like a
woman like Jazelle yet ever
really ever seeing them for who they are
like they could literally walk into the
room with their head on fire and Jazelle
still wouldn't notice them and as they
watched Tom Brady March down the field
towards yet another championship
somewhere in their in their
brain the truth of that is is is
screaming at
them I went to a dark place whatever I'm
in the [__] Midwest starting to cut
the crops down um I was at the the
embassy theater last night and uh I
actually watched this whole video on
that um I love old theaters that were
going to get [__] torn down and
people saved them that's actually
um one of my uh soft spots as far as uh
something I could get behind I actually
did a gig in Fresno and I talked to the
guy and he was like still trying to
raise money to keep that thing going and
I that reminded me how I told him I was
going to go up there maybe do a show or
something like that I can't remember if
it was in Fresno if it was the one in uh
Bakersfield
I don't remember but they were both
great theaters and um I watched this
whole video on it and like like Bob Hope
had his first MC gig here just the level
they always have the same history these
old theaters was always like it was a
Vaudeville
theater you know and then it became a
movie
theater and then uh you know it starts
to go down and like the late 50s and 60s
becomes a porno house and then in the'
70s they were going to tear it down and
then somebody came in and saved the
[__] thing and now it's awesome again
and uh the embassy theater basically had
that same thing minus the porno house it
was never a porno house which makes
sense here because they don't sell booze
on Sundays like all the liquor stores
are closed they don't even sell beer out
here but
um dude they got a they got a minor
league uh whatever basketball team out
here it's called The Mad Ants
how [__] hilarious a [__] great
name the Fort Wayne Mad
Ants um I'm a nerve for this [__] I love
the stuff out here I used to have family
lived out here you know way back way
back like a hundred years ago and um
they had a farm this is they have this
weird connection out even though I
didn't grow up out here my bloodline is
from out here Indiana Michigan Ohio all
of that [__] so I have this weird
connection when I come out here um you
know I had family lived in Wisconsin all
these places that I'm going to so like
there going to the city was Chicago you
know that was the big deal and um so
anyways and I was hoping when I was
going to go to
Chicago that the [__] Cubs were going
to be in the World Series how exciting
would that be how exciting would that be
and uh now look at it oh by by the way
can we go back a second those F I don't
understand people who thought that we
were going to beat the Colts by a
thousand [__] points the Colts made
it to the AFC Championship game
I I I just don't [__] understand how
people look at it and ESPN hyped it up
that way and then during the game
they're going like well what's going on
here everybody thought that they were
going to f it's like what cuz Tom
Brady's dad says score [__] 60 points
on them all of a sudden that's the line
that's like watching Toronto play in
Kansas City they hit one walk-off home
run and flip their [__]
mullets you
know
and do you know you know you [__]
actors run in musical theater that
attitude
run where they start to run sideways
looking at the crowd and then D like the
head Whip and then
[__] run off stage with their arms
dangling behind him that's how Toronto
ran the bases and everybody's like oh
[__] here come the Blue
Jays given Kansas City no respect
whatsoever Kansas City went to the dance
last year they almost won the [__]
World Series and here comes Toronto
these dirty filthy bird
[__] come wson in like it's a for gone
conclusion that they're going to the
World Series and now look at you you got
the old right there Fred you're down out
too all right so why don't you quit
flipping your [__] bats and get back
to playing the goddamn game so a fan
like me can enjoy a nice seven game
series now look at you you dumb [__] you
got to win four out of
five so anyways
um I I love Kansas City man I love the
[__] Royals um goes way back in the
day when the Red Sox could never beat
the [__] Yankees and like
like three times in four
years Kansas City played uh played the
Yankees in the for the pennant is how
they used to say it they're playing for
the pennant it wasn't the ALCS back then
it was just for the penet right look at
me and I you sit on the corner selling
newspapers for a nickels step right up
step right up
extra X to Read All About
It Dodge has a new car called Le
opal um and that's the way it was
1977 um so they played him as 77 and 78
and lost and then they played him in 81
or played him in 80 and W and then lost
to the Phillies in the uh in the world
serious there
um so
anyways yeah I got this weird thing I
don't like the Toronto Blue Jays I don't
want them winning Our World Series I
feel like our world series trophy
belongs here in America it's one of the
weird like patriotic things that I have
like Toronto played the Yankees I'd
actually root for the Yankees as much as
it would kill me but you know what the
[__] do I care they got 27 championships
so I give a [__] if they get 28 we're
not catching them right it's a for gone
conclusion you know they went on the Run
whoever goes on the run early
on you know they they have it forever
[__] Montreal when you [__]
winning them like before the Titanic
sank nobody's going to catch you if you
went on a run back then you're not going
to there was like nine [__] teams and
you you had to win like two two playoff
series dude in baseball do you know if
you won the division that was winning
the pennant there was no ALCS no wild
card no nothing he just immediately went
to the World Series so you had to win
one playoff series so I got to tell you
I got this weird thing with that like
you know even like the Celtics when we
won like a we won 11 in a row or 9 in a
row 11 in [__] you know 13 years or
something like that I mean come
on come on you that's that's beer league
[__] that's what's so amazing about the
Lakers is we did that and the Lakers
still came and caught us I mean that's
why I think you know they're the
greatest [__] franchise in the modern
era since 1970 and they won more
championships than anybody since then
and as much as it [__] kills me to
say that it's true it's [__] true um
they that devastating combination of of
they knew how to pick talent and then
when it came into the free agency era uh
they knew how to play that game and we
didn't and that hurt us and also Len Bas
dying [__] us out of at least one to
three championships depending on who you
talk to oh my God Len we got Len Bias in
1986 our strongest [__] team and then
we're going to have Len
Bias basically Jordan light was we I me
we were all so excited oh my God we
finally going to have a Celtic that can
dunk you know cuz all the Celtics fans
as much as they didn't want to admit it
it watching the showtime Lakers was so
much [__] fun if they weren't playing
the Celtics cuz you know then you're
rooting for the Celtics but I used to
watch them all the [__] they were on TV
I loved watching the
Lakers the [__] Showtime Lakers come
on man I was actually talking last night
when we were on the bus hanging out and
we were watching uh the end of the
Patriots it was so [__] great man we
had the bus right behind the theater and
uh the theater hooked us up like a nine
pack of uh Miller lights with the giant
[__] opening you know so you can pour
it down your [__] bass mouth and uh
we were sitting in there verie was
finishing up a cigar outside right and
we were talking about uh bartnik goes
all right you're you're Mount
Rushmore of football
coaches and he said Lombardi Chuck null
Bill W bill
bich and I said the exact same thing I
said I said except not Chuck
null
um and I picked uh what's his face I
just spaced on his [__]
name um Don
Corel Eric
Corel I just thought he was ahead of his
[__]
time and uh it really informed I think
Bill Walsh coming up with the [__] uh
West Coast offense there was nothing
more
exciting in the than in the late 7s
early ' 80s the San Diego Chargers on
Monday Night Football knowing that they
were going to throw the ball on first
down I you don't understand what the
what a game changer that was we was 10
years away from three yards in a cloud
of dust where you just [__] ran it
ran it ran it and then you just threw it
if you had to which is why Johnny
United's [__] numbers are insane the
fact that he threw for 41,000 yard yards
during the 50s and 60s is is [__]
insane and which is why he's always in
my top three four quarterbacks of all
time but
anyways to watch I don't know I
absolutely love those guys
um I don't know how the [__] I got onto
that thing let me read some advertising
here before uh I completely space out
here we got a couple of new people here
we always got new people it's a
revolving door here in this [__]
podcast with the advertising all right
all right how many more of these are
there there's two more let's uh let's
break it up dude my [__] brain is
tired today I'm tired this morning oh
Jesus I'm tired hey how about those
Bruins how about those [__] BR who
wins they won two games in a row why am
I singing the Notre Dame song oh that's
right I went to the game um yeah I went
to the Notre Dame game everybody that's
a bucketless
thing I can just uh I can just knock
that right off now where the [__] is all
my my notes Here there I had all the
subjects I wanted to talk
about what the [__] is
this oh for God's
sakes why is this I you know what it is
I always have 50 [__] windows
open let's close this one let's close
this
one look it it's a [__]
Enigma where where did it
go where does the window go now you
won't go
up is this it is this it come on there
it is all right
beautiful
um anyways what was I talking I want you
to Notre Dame game man what a [__]
game there was absolutely no defense and
you know what I finally broke the curse
I'm no longer a jinx the home team won
congratulations to Notre dve um my God
it was crazy walking that campus it was
really weird I walked that last time I
walked that campus was like I was a
freshman in high school and I was out
here visiting uh
family and we went down to go look at it
and I was all excited to see the stadium
and uh thinking that I was actually
going to get grades good enough to go
there and I was going to go to law
school and become a lawyer and
uh that was like 30 [__] years ago to
come back 30 years
later dude it was more than 30 years ago
it was like around
8384 god I'm an old [__] now
it's
2015 and it come
back
drunk as a stand-up
comedian you
know walking that campus just thinking
what the [__] happened just thinking of
all the [__] that happened to me since
then I remember I was walking you know
hammered of
course and
uh laughing as I was walking the campus
and I went you kind of took a different
route there Billy B this family of sober
people just kind of looked over at me
and I was just like hey you know I'm
going down memory lane here a little
shitfaced got me some slack last time I
was here Ronnie Reagan was still alive
and he was eating jelly beains right
blaming everything on oi north um all
right the Jesus Christ what a [__]
game we saw a game where there was over
a th yards offense there was absolutely
no defense and I got to tell you I get
so [__]
livid at fans from the other team at
home games of teams that I have no I
don't have a dog in the fight I don't
give a [__] there was two USC fans that
were driving me nuts there was one
Samoan looking dude I was calling him
MOSI tatupu any Patriot fans you
remember that he probably wasn't even
Simone remember M these mooses and you
be in this the [__] Endzone m o s i
MOSI it's a [__] incredible player
for the Patriots like all sens
are you know USC for some reason had the
lock on sowen players and they realized
that these guys are like they're like
they're not even good players they're
like Hall of Fame
players for some reason they were the
only ones that were drafting them they
going out there and flying out and
talking to their mothers lying to them
saying your kids going to make the
[__] NFL and we're going to [__]
fix up your [__] house out here
whatever the [__] they tell these
goddamn kids um
so he was doing that [__] and every time
you know Notre Dame first play like
throws a [__] 70 yard bomb for a
touchdown and he does that stupid thing
you know where your team just got scored
on and then you sit there nodding like
okay okay like we can handle this we can
handle this and you want to be like
excuse me sir you're not on the team
what are you nodding for and then there
was this [__] old white guy with the
most faded [__]
USC jacket and hat so you could tell he
was a [__] real fan who sat out there
in the LA Coliseum I mean it was like Su
damaged clothes that he was wearing was
just like his skin you know white people
will wear [__] till it's fallen off our
[__] bodies you know what I mean I'm
telling
you we're [__] I don't know what we
are we're sentimental and cheap we don't
[__] put lotion on our faces our
faces is all are all [__] Sun damaged
this guy was a mess man this guy looked
like a [__] dust B farmer and you
know he was from LA right one of those
douchebags and they both bonded and they
kept high-fiving each other and they
were [__] annoying me I was sitting
there going why am I so mad that these
USC fans are USC
fans I just hate it when the other teams
fans come in and they take over the
[__] Stadium but what I was psyched
about is who sitting around all Notre
Dame fans except for this one USC douche
who showed up in the third quarter with
his girlfriend wearing this like camel
hair coat it almost seemed with a scarf
draped over it
and it was just such a [__] I a he
was such a douche he was such a douche
you had to like respect it
um he just looked like that guy you were
going to see on American Greed when he
was in his 50s just complete
sociopath completely entitled the whole
[__] thing like you know they have
that expression he's a comic's
comic you know a musician's musici this
kid we were joking was he was like the
douches
douche like douchebags would looked at
him like oh look at he's [__]
crushing it just in at one point my
favorite part of the game cuz you know
he was a USC fan I heard him talking all
douchy and loudly and Notre Dame was
down on the goal line they stacked like
three receivers on one side and he's
just like look at that formation why
would they stick all those guys there
then of course Notre Dame runs it up the
middle for a touchdown and I just turn I
look at him I said oh it's cuz it clears
out the middle and he's like oh we're
not even good this year year that's what
he said oh he just wanted to [__]
choke him right this goddamn scarf and
listening to him losing faith like I
just want I like the old me would
actually got into with them being like
dude why are you cheering this you
showed up in the [__] third
quarter but you probably been like oh
that's because I spent the first two
quarters in the Press
Box my last name is Trojan my dad owns
the university you know he's one of
these [__] [__] you know but of
course you know it was with a
good-looking
girlfriend she does she's at that age
you know what I mean she's going to hit
your wagon to that she she's with a
[__] absolute
sweetheart God that's got to suck man if
you have a daughter right and she just
marries a
douche you know the two first of all you
don't want you don't want her to be
hanging around some [__] [__] Hound
either cuz you're like all right this
guy's going to cheat on her break her
[__] heart blah blah blah blah BL
give her a [__] STD and then you got
the other thing if just Mary's a douche
you know know you got that weird feeling
where like okay at least she'll be taken
care of cuz you know he has money cuz
he's a douche and doesn't care about
things and would pour [__] in the water
supply if it got him another scarf in
life right so you want him to come home
with like a [__] you want her to come
home with a [__]
uh I don't know with like a nice guy but
then you meet him he's a nice guy and
then somewhere you're going to resent
that kind to be like this guy's too
[__]
nice to really go out and make it you
know you is going to accept things you
know
and make pumpkin bread
and I'm a [__] idiot all right let me
just let me just plow ah head here let's
get to the questions oh by the way I saw
a movie on the plane ride out here a
movie that I wanted to see uh there was
a movie uh called dope that came out I
think last year it's [__]
brilliant it's such a great movie and
the performances in it and the way it's
written um the whole thing wir to wire
was just
done so perfectly U it's one of the best
movies I saw I was riding out with my
buddy we were on the same flight and um
we got another passenger to switch so we
were [__] hanging and drinking on the
way out to go this [__] game we just
had the best [__] time and uh I
started watching that movie and within
like five minutes I'm Lally [__] give
him the elbow going dude you got to put
this [__] movie on and um just the
whole way that they executed the thing
was
phenomenal um so definitely check it out
you're like what's it about it's about
uh a kid who lives in the inner city and
he's not in a gang and he sucks at
Sports and he's a [__]
nerd he's a total [__] geek it's the
kind of
basically black kid that they NE really
never put in movies you know what I mean
cuz it's like the other two are exciting
are living exciting lives like when
you're in a gang there's life and death
[__] going on and then you know if
you're [__] playing in sports you
know what I mean that's like uh you know
3 2 1 you're going to have that whole
movie thing going and sad to say those
are the two [__] kinds of
like black guys that they put on TV they
in gangs on Cops and then on TV crushing
your team's hopes and dreams that's it
they they never show the [__] nerds
that are down there that enjoy books and
want to go to college and want to get
the [__] out of there so not only that
is it an original thing like oh this
part of the city and they're going to do
this this feels new it's actually
socially a great thing to show there I'm
off my [__] tree stump it's a [__]
great movie all right let's plow ahead
here um so the Cubbies are down
2 Toronto is down
20 um there's this weird thing that you
know if the Cubs are in in the World
Series um I'm going to be in Chicago at
that time doing three nights three
nights of shows and my agent was already
worried going dude that city is going to
[__] shut down so there's a
possibility we'd have to move the the
the shows later or you know who knows
what the deal is going to be we have to
accommodate the people of
Chicago so I'm like I don't give a [__]
move the move it later I don't give a
[__] I'll scalp a ticket and go to the
game and he goes all right done deal so
I actually really like the Mets this
year because uh one of the guys I work
with on FIS for family sweetheart of a
guy is a big Mets fan he's a [__]
DieHard Mets fan and when it looked like
the Mets was [__] in the bed he had this
happy go-lucky attitude about it going
like you know cuz he actually got me
into it like back in August I go to the
Mets wi last night he just laughs he
goes no we lost again like I'm sorry he
goes yeah we're going to blow it we're
going to blow it I go you still going to
watch so I goes yep going to watch every
game so just seeing a true fan like that
it kind of got me on the [__]
bandwagon um but I also love the Cubs
too I actually for some reason it makes
no sense as a Boston fan I kind of
really like the Mets too but I also you
know the Cubs you got to root for the
Cubs being a Red Sox fan solidarity
they're going through a curse I want to
see them win right get that monkey off
the back as much as I can't stand people
who wave hankes during [__] games I
give you a pass if you're a Steelers fan
cuz they came up with it the Terrible
Towel you
know for the love of God can you be a
[__] sports fan and put your hanky
Down Standing Up waving that thing the
people behind you can't see it's the
playoffs playoffs people want to see it
um all right let's read some [__]
questions here for the
week uh yeah yeah the playoffs come
around all the douches come out with the
[__] noise makers and the hankes and
the signs get out of the [__] way
there's a reason why there's stadium
seating so the person behind you can see
you start standing up flailing your
[__] arms around trying to get on
TV the rally
monkey GH all right Halloween
movies um hey there Billy on Elm
Street um I would have gone with night
bur on Elm Street uh are you into horror
movies I've heard every podcast and I'm
not sure you've ever talked about it uh
what movie Scared you as a kid uh there
was a movie where this [__] Maniac
this chick was skating I've I've talked
about this before she was figure skating
and then all of a sudden this [__]
hockey playing Jason they just show him
skating in slow motion with his big
Muppet shoes right that was the funny
thing they couldn't give him like I
don't think they gave him real skates
because it would have seemed too [__]
normal he still had on his Frankenstein
shoes with blades underneath it starts
[__] skating look like the Muppet's
on ice but then you see he has an like a
sickle starts skating towards this
[__] lady and he pulls out the
[__] this sickle and she's got the
stupid chick figure skates right where
you can only do that [__] scissor run
you know what I mean you can't do the
[__] hockey thing it's so [__]
hilar to me that they gave chicks that
you know you figed that fact that
especially back in the day you know what
I
mean where so many sexual assaults were
like well what were you wearing you were
asking for You' figur that they'd give
the women the better skates so then the
[__] rapist guys would you know would
have to do that [__] figure skating
scissor thing to try to catch him as
they [__] would fly up the ice and
they'd get away you
know it's a travesty that one scared me
and the first night uh um Friday the
13th Friday the 13th part one and two
were scary and then once it went into 3D
kind of went off the
rails
um Dark Knight of the
Scarecrow scared the [__] out of me old
school once um there was an old uh
Sesame Street one that scared me where
they were trying to teach you
about the number one or being alone or
something they don't show it anymore cuz
it scared the [__] out of me and years
later I talked to my younger brother
about it and said it scared the [__] out
of him too so I imagine somebody wrote
to the show saying it was freaking kids
out he starts the song and he's on the
piano and he's singing and there was
like three other Muppets there and by
the end of it he was all by himself and
he was running around going hey where'd
everybody go and he couldn't figure out
how to get out and you [__] scared
the [__] I don't know what the [__] it
was the age I was at it was that whole
thought of being alone and not near your
par parents I was just old enough to
understand that I didn't know what the
[__] I was doing I couldn't drive a car
and that uh I'd never see anybody that I
knew anymore and what the f it was like
one of the most terrifying things all
right so I went to Sesame Street there
um
anyways he said what movie Scared you as
an adult anything you you can tolerate
as an adult my personal favorite was The
Omen what was the one where the guy fell
under the ice and they were digging at
the ice as he [__] went by that one
scared me dude the Blair Witch scared
the [__] out of me I saw that by myself
the midnight showing I totally Buy in
when I go to scary movies uh the ring
scared the [__] out of me I found the
American one more scarier than the the
the Japanese
one
um and some of that [__] over there the
the audition did you ever see that one
old boy did you see that
one Bobby Lee told me to go see those
two Bobby Lee knows all about those
[__] things things and yes it is
because he's Asian and he is a movie
star and you combine the two of those
and he's going to give you some great
[__] movies
um yeah I I'm one of those guys that I
buy into it I hate people go to scary
movies and be like that movie didn't
even scare me I was laughing through the
whole thing you know like all of a
sudden now they're like a war hero it's
like yeah you're at a
movie the whole time if you're at a
[__] movie you just start looking
around at the movie theater yeah you're
not going to be scared but if you
actually buy in which is what you're
supposed to do you [__] actually have
a good time you [__] all right um
ex-girlfriend hinting at possible
reunion oh
[Music]
GES
um ex-girlfriend Hing a possible reunion
hey Bill love your podcast even though
I'm a lady and think you have no women
fans oh I assumed this was a guy look at
me being all heterosexual here I'll just
get right into it and say I've been
having some lady problems my
ex-girlfriend do you know how bad I want
to have a beer with you you and talk to
a [__] woman about women problems
just to hear that [__]
perspective you know with your [__]
Insight being a woman you know what what
are your moves how do you [__] walk
through that mind
field she goes my ex-girlfriend whom I
loved for a long time and used the word
whom I never know how to use that
correctly if anybody can send me
something I've read it on you know I I
know how to use your and your
and two and two t o I know how to use
those
right but uh who and whom have always
stumped me my ex-girlfriend whom I'm
just assuming you're using it correctly
I've Loved for a long time keep saying
she misses me and hinting at us getting
back together even though we've been
broken up for like 5 years it's one of
those relationships that never seems to
die not in the sense that we keep
breaking up and getting back together
we've never done that but that we can't
just be like normal friends there's
there's always some underlying romantic
feelings in our
interactions yeah that sounds like you
guys had that sex Vibe you know what I
mean and then you're both relationship
people and next thing you know you're
hanging out you're having great sex and
then next thing you know you're in a
relationship and then you really realize
like you know we just sort of [__]
each other's brains out but other than
that there was nothing else there but
then every time you run into each other
is still that hey we can go [__] each
other's brains out that you canuse for
the spark of love that's what I'm
guessing so far anyways in case you're
not familiar with it this is typical
lesbian
drama I I didn't realize that but it
makes sense you got the same Hardware
you know how the engine runs that you
would
probably I would think that you guys
were all [__] crushing it out there
right anyways it's widely believed that
we just can't let go she had a
girlfriend up until a few days ago but
kept flirting with me even when they
broke up well she's a piece of [__] then
you can't get with her you can't she's
[__] around on this other broad right
now she keeps saying stuff like what do
you think it's going to be like when
we're old and married oh
God and she goes oh I forgot you don't
oh she goes oh and I forgot you don't
want to get married I'm okay with us
just living together I don't know if
she's kidding or what so I just try to
Dodge it by saying stuff like I don't
know maybe I'll be dead by then yeah
exactly she's getting in your [__]
head I neither confirm nor reject the
idea of us getting back together I just
let her run with it I'm not even sure
why she's doing
this um she wants to talk to me all the
time now and I'm thinking maybe she's
needy and has been and has been for some
time since her relationship wasn't going
that well that's what I would guess and
I'm just a safe Target for her to throw
her emotions at and get something back
there you go there you go I agree with
all of that but then she talked about
how she will never love anyone as much
as she loved me and when I asked her if
she still loves me she said
yes oh you know what can I ask you a
question do you love her were you
thinking were you even thinking about
this broad until she got back into your
[__] life she's going to [__] turn
you all around oh God let me read the
rest of this but I don't know what kind
of love and what she wants with me if
she's serious of just having fun I'm not
going to say I've never thought about it
but I'm not sure if I'd ever go back to
that relationship we broke up for a
reason and even though there's still
something there it seems like a huge
step backward in a way well there's your
answer what the hell does she want Bill
she wants your [__]
clamp she wants to nuzzle up next year
and have somebody watch a movie with and
[__] around with again until she can
[__] drive you nuts and you got to go
through the emotional drama again and
why now you already answered the
question cuz she's recently single and
she's lonely thanks for your time and
your free podcast uh lesbophobic
grandmother oh that's the next question
I thought tell you signed it I'm like
wait a minute you're grandmother and
you're afraid of lesbians you are a
lesbian what are the odds that was going
to be the next one sorry about that um I
would say uh yeah I would not get back
involved with her [__] that [__] that
you're still
young go get yourself some hot peace
[__] is into you so it can be
exciting and new Come
Aboard where two lesbians let's hang
out and wear our shets together
please um yeah that's what I would do I
would move on oh what she wants you now
because she's recently single [__] that
she's using you all right you're better
than that you're better than that [__]
that and don't give in the fact you know
just the way this whole thing's written
I feel like you're a you're a better
person and that you actually have more
genuine feelings you know what I mean
which means you're going to be more
vulnerable and easier prey and I think
she's coming in you know she's basically
the lesbian version of the dude that sat
behind me during the USC game the douche
is douche she's like the lesbians [__]
you know does that make any sense
probably doesn't but I'm looking out for
you here I would say do not get back
together with her all right especially
over the holidays you know that
Wednesday before Thanksgiving when you
just want to go out and go to that place
you know basically the lesbian
cheers sometimes you want to go right
everybody knows your name and she's
going to be sitting in there drinking
some sort of pumpkin
beer you know comes walking up to you
wearing her Dickies yeah you don't need
that [__] [__]
that go talk to that younger hotti in
the sundress do yourself a you know
treat yourself this holiday season get
yourself a younger Hardy in a sundress
all right lesbophobic
grandmother uh dear Billy ball
buster before I get to what I want to
talk about I just want to say that I'm a
big dude and you sir have inspired me to
lose weight good man since April 3rd
I've been working out almost every day
and I've lost 35 pounds so thank you for
that bill you're a legend dude you're a
legend that's [__]
tremendous that's what you got to do go
to the gym every day my big thing is I'm
on the road for 2 weeks here so you know
um I've actually stayed on my gym
schedule I went to to the gym the first
day second day was my day off and now
the next three days in a row I do three
on one day off so uh I'm doing my
podcast and we're driving down to
Cincinnati so when I get to
Cincinnati um you know it's not a long
drive so I'm going to I'm going to do
the old treadmill hopefully they'll have
a pull-up bar or something there um so I
can do my pull-ups and that type of [__]
[__] um cuz I have a bet with Paul ver
that when I'm 70 I'm be able to do 10 of
those [__] things I was actually
thinking the other day if I can Pat
myself on the back as I was on my
pegboard in my garage which I have the
long skinny one that I actually hung
sideways so I just go along the thing
sideways because you know you need like
[__] you need like a [__] you know
10 10t ceiling probably 11 with the size
of my head to go up a pegboard and have
the head room to get up to the top and I
didn't want to hang it lower and start
you know with my [__] basically on my
knees for for whatever reason I didn't
want to do that um and I was going
across the pegboard and I was actually
thinking at some point going dude I'm 47
years old going across a pegboard at
some point I got to be impressed that's
pretty
impressive um and after Burke ker gave
me that that Men's Health thing to
increase your grip strength that really
helped me on the [__] pegboard
um and also my technique I held you know
when you you hold it you got to have it
your you're basically your forearms
almost touching your bicep you got to
have it and then the rest of your arm is
basically right on your side you got to
get in close um so you got more leverage
I was almost I had my arm too far away
from my chest and I I couldn't do it um
so anyways he goes a few years back my
parents got divorced after 17 years of a
bad marriage we put the final nail in
the cof was my mother's secret
relationship with another
lady who is now her girlfriend who I'll
call Kate for the sake of this email
Kate with the K not with the c like old
Bruce there she has since moved in with
us which sounds weird but my brother
sister and I all have a great
relationship with Kate um also I wasn't
it wasn't just something my oh my God
can you imagine that poor bastard what a
mind [__] that
is
dude if you're in a relationship okay
and it ends and it turns out the other
person's gay I mean you have to be
sitting there going this person never
loved
me I just
wasted my [__] life and then on top
of
that your family
bonds with the new [__]
lover that just that's just a double
mind [__] like is there any sympathy for
me what the [__] I'm going through I
legitimately love this [__]
woman wow anyway she has since moved in
with us which sounds weird my brothers
and sisters and I have a great
relationship with Kate well that's I
mean yeah that's good that's actually
Progressive also wasn't just something
my
mom uh also it wasn't just something my
mom just drove into in spite of my dad
my mom and Kate really do love each
other and they have three strong years
together to back that up dude you got
any sympathy for your
dad uh here's the problem my grandmother
has grown farther and farther apart from
my mother ever since she turned
lesbian turned lesbian no dude she
always she was always
there uh she pretty much hates Kate dude
by the way you can't turn gay you're gay
you know what I
mean you just you're [__] gay it's
like did you turn
heterosexual was it a decision you made
you know at like four or
five [__] years of age the first time
that's the first time I
remember I I always tell this [__]
story whenever somebody says turn gay
it's like you are what you are I
remember I was laying on the floor they
had this giant rug when I was in
kindergarten and this girl asked to get
up and go to the bathroom she could go
to the bathroom and I was laying there
playing with some [__] toy you know
holding it up like a little kid does and
when she walked by me she walked by
close enough that I could see upper
skirt to see her 5-year-old thigh which
sounds weird but I was five so I was
crushing it right and when I saw it you
know I felt like this [__] jolt in my
heart and I remember I sat up and I just
turned around and stared at her as she
walked out like what the [__] was that
you know this wasn't a decision made so
I imagine if you were
gay right am I really going to talk
about 5-year-old balls I can't do that
um yeah it's basically the same thing
but to say that you turned gay would
mean that you also turned heterosexual
which mean at some point you were
sitting there and you know
metaphorically or hypothetically
whatever the proper word is there was a
dick and a [__] on the table and you
were going e mey my let's see what are
we going to choose here let's weigh the
options you didn't you were just
straight all right anyways so she pretty
much hates Kate and she believes she has
perverted my
mom uh she won't even so much as come
over for a meal and I can barely mention
Kate around her mind you my grandmother
lives only nine houses down from us
here's my question is there any way to
make my grandmother more accepting of my
mother my mother and Kate her option
hasn't budged in 3 years and I'd love
for her to at least be cordial your
infinite and hilarious wisdom will be
greatly appreciated thanks and go [__]
yourself
um
no I'm sorry I usually offer a ray of
light there
isn't there is it this is going to be of
these deathbed things that she's going
to have to [__] do they just there
isn't um when somebody feels that
way feels that strongly um all I can say
is just keep inviting her to stuff maybe
eventually she'll come around I was
surprised that in all of this she didn't
have any nothing about your
dad and the [__] that he had to go
through I mean that's [__]
unbelievable you know they actually did
an article about that you know when when
Bruce became Kate you know and they were
going oh my God isn't this amazing this
is [__] you know and the a it'ss the
Fourth of July because everybody was so
afraid to be on the wrong side of that
issue that all of a sudden you know
they'd lose their advertising and then
they couldn't make their mortgages
that's what most of that reaction was
about I felt was about you know cover
your ass let's get out in front of this
story and show how much we uh you know
we are accepting of this or like the
pieces of [__] ESPN
Let's ignore a woman dying of cancer
who's still playing basketball and let's
make [__] Kate the Sportsman of the
year so that we get the exclusive
interview with her [__] pieces of
[__]
um
anyways the [__] am I going with this
like they actually did this article an
informed article on it that wasn't
homophobic but actually talked about the
people that were
married and the the depression and
Devastation that they go through cuz
they you know they lose that person you
know what I mean like Bruce Jenner is
gone and if you loved Bruce if you're in
a [__] relationship you know with
them like his wife
was I mean all of a just poof just
[__] just bad enough you go through a
[__] it's almost like they
died so I mean there is like a crazy
thing there or if you have a
relationship where all of a sudden
there's nothing more definitive I think
that if your your partner never [__]
loved you the way you loved them if not
only do you go through a divorce that
they then you find out that the whole
time that they were gay so it's just
like I I would be going like oh my God
so was I like grossing you out every
time we had sex I would be [__]
devastated so I was a little surprised
you got nothing in there about your dad
I mean he must be like H [__] he must
he is he crushing it maybe he's got some
[__]
young chick on the side I have no idea
but I'm getting away from the uh the
thing here
um I would say no there's there's no way
when somebody's that walled
off and you
know on one level you just got to be
accepting of your grandmother that like
she grew up in a different time and her
child brain was filled up with this [__]
and you know it's it's [__] atrophied
in there there's nothing you can do
about it
but
I don't know just keep coming over I you
know what I would do I would openly
jokeing I would openly joke about it in
front of her to loosen her
up you
know uh that's what I would
do I just remembered when we remember
that guy that old guy that lived beneath
me last time when I had the apartment
way back in the day he used to always
yell at my wife through the floors and
he was a [__] [__] we just started
being overly nice to him my wife started
whistling at him like he was a good-look
guy and we [__] basically wore the
guy down and at some point you know you
know before the dementia set in and he
totally went [__] crazy you know was
standing out on the [__] porch with
just a t-shirt on that was a hell of a
sight
um I would just openly joke about
it
um I would just be like uh I would start
calling her Kate the you hate that's
what I would do hey my mom and Kate that
you hate is going down to the
store hey you know Katie that you hatey
yeah they're going uh they're going to
go to the movies they're probably
holding hands right now Grandma they're
holding hands grandma like I would just
do
that I'd be like come on Grandma there
was never one you
know you never had one half a second gay
moment you
know it was just one girl I don't know
what she did you're just admiring her
beauty and you I don't know maybe you
just wanted to kiss her on her shoulder
and just try to gross her out I'm just
Kidd I would I would you know what I
would break her balls about
it every time I saw her I would do that
in the beginning and then I would talk
to her about whatever I wanted to talk
about that's what I would do and see if
he could and then I would tell Kate that
that's what I'm doing and then when Kate
was
there I'd be like Grandma there's Kate
think you hate
oh Haiti Katie there she is look at her
you know as much as you hate her you got
to admit this is a hell of a meatloaf
sandwich granted you know you don't want
to know where those those fingers were
when you she was making it don't don't
take it that far sorry I had to get out
of it with a joke um all
right
girlfriend uh [__] a yoga instructor
hey old Billy bald tits how the [__] are
you uh I'm writing you because I need
some advice I just recently found out my
girlfriend of 2 years has
done some [__] up [__] up until now I
thought she was marriage material she's
not like the Kardashian wannabes of
today she and I have so much in common
we always laugh and I love hanging out
with her no red
lights no red flags you mean have been
triggered until
now uh she doesn't drink like crazy she
doesn't take off her heels and walk home
she's not a quitter overall she's
awesome but recently I found out from a
mutual friend that before she met me she
had a secret affair with her yoga
instructor and that's not even the
[__] up part the yoga instructor is
also her best friend's
dad what okay her best friend's dead and
she never told her best
friend oh my
God so that yoga instructor [__] his
daughter's best friend dude that is such
yoga instructor
Behavior dude I'm telling you right now
in another [__] life I would have
been a yoga instructor dude those guys
[__] crush it like
nobody dude hot chicks they all [__]
do yoga right cuz they want to stay in
shape but they don't want to get all
[__] bulked up they want to keep that
seny type muscle right they want to be
all tone but still look good in the
[__] dress right so
like the pi Piper They just come to you
and you get them all stretched out
before you [__] them and then you can
have your whole new AG blah blah blah
dude I'm tell you right now take a yoga
[__] class one time in your life and
you know who the yoga instructor wants
to bang it's the one they always go over
and they adjust them and they put their
hands on them you know you know what I
mean they get the the woman gets to feel
their [__] touch and they're all
[__] open cuz they're [__] in this
head space like the whole the [__]
Vibe is it's it's a
layup you know what's funny I used to
take this [__] yoga class and this
guy was like crushing it and for some
reason I was always doing the positions
correctly he never had to adjust me but
the [__] chick next to me who was
already totally stretchy and could put
her foot up her own goddamn clam for
some reason he always had to [__]
adjust her with their spaghetti straps
huh [__]
hilarious ah you got to love a piece of
[__] yoga instructor I I [__] oh
they're such dirt bags and the whole
time they're talking about all this new
Agy stuff you know just be man you can't
fight it you know just [__] give into
my dick um anyways he said they [__]
for a few
months before she met
me and came clean to telling me uh that
it was true but she regrets it what the
[__] do I do I'm young I'm only 22 but I
feel like I have really found some
someone in her her but I feel like I
can't trust someone who would be that
deceitful should I move on or assume
something like this won't happen in the
future thanks a million Anders always go
[__] yourself well those are two really
great
questions
um you
know in defense of her she's really
young and I'm assuming that [__] guy
is at least in his
40s and what he did was barely legal you
know dude that guy [__] spit 20 years
a game at her dur in a yoga class I mean
it's a [__]
layup um but
also she did [__] a guy she did [__] her
friend's
dad
so if she's the way that you say where
she's this really wholesome innocent
type person those people are also you
know the kinds of people that end up in
the trunk of cial kill his carss I hate
to say it because they are so [__]
innocent and that type of [__] so you
know this guy's basically Jason except
instead of an axe he's using his dick I
mean that's just [__] that's
[__] oh my God I can't imagine doing
that I can't [__] can you
imagine right after you bust a nut and
you're you're thinking clearly again
what the [__] you just
did
and you know women are so [__]
emotional right Jesus Christ like and
they just have to talk you never rob a
bank with a woman I mean you're caught
before it's even started and then you do
something like that and then oh my God I
feel so bad I feel about bad and she
goes out and has a couple of [__]
lady drinks and the whole [__] town
knows oh my God then your daughter is
going to hate you for life your marriage
is [__] over I mean Jesus [__]
Christ jeez that guy might he might as
well stuck his dick in a
beehive son of a [__] got away with it
cuz he's a [__] yoga instructor man
um yeah I don't know I would just really
come clean to her and I would just sit
down and say
listen
um just tell her all these great things
that you feel about her but
the the fact that she did it did
that you just need to talk about it more
like just ask her walk way through it
like why do you think you did that just
don't accuse her don't be like don't be
having an accusatory tone don't be
judging her even though you
are um I think the jury's still out on
that because she's so [__] young and
that piece of [__] is so [__]
old um he really took advantage of her I
don't give I know it's [__] legal but
to me in my head like yeah you're a
[__] pervert if you do something like
that I'm judging the guy I mean she was
2122 when he did it but that that that's
not [__]
right that's that's not [__] right
you
know
[Music]
um Jesus [__]
Christ I've seen pornno with a more
wholesome storyline than that you know
um no I would just ask her about it and
just why do you why do you do that why
did you do that why why do you think
that you did it I would help her
get through it in a therapy way and just
buy her answers if uh you know if that's
like what she's
into then I would have some concerns
that she would act out
again um I don't know I would I but I
but if you love her you really got to
sit down in a nonjudge judgmental way
and by the way dude you're telling me
you haven't stuck your dick in some
place that would give her a little some
[__] red flags you never did anything
fil Heth y you
know I mean I'm assuming you did why
don't you be fair and kind of it's this
weird thing where like you should be
before you marry somebody you you have
to you got to judge them you don't just
walk into it
blindly you're agreeing to spend your
life with somebody you you got to judge
them harshly but um she already feels
bad about it you know you don't want to
hurt her but there's there's a way more
of like a therapy kind of way you could
just ask her like why why do you think
that you did that and if she goes well
why are you still asking me about it
which she might she might get defensive
I would just
say I I don't know because I it's it
concerns me that's a bad answer what do
you mean it concerns you don't judge me
oh Jesus dude this going be like
dismantling a
bumb
I just I mean it's a a hell of a story
like how did you keep that a secret how
did you feel about that she probably
needed to get it off her [__] chest I
think the fact that she had to admit it
to you shows that she's not a complete
sociopath you know I don't
know let me know how that one goes I
gave you the best advice I could all
right uh by curious girlfriend Jesus
this is like the red shoe Diaries this
[__] week huh
um hey Bill recently I found out that my
girlfriend who I've been uh with for a
year now has been searching on the
internet for naked girls and porn with
hot girls as I was on her phone in front
of her not snooping oh yeah I'm sure you
weren't snooping this was of course news
to me and I confronted her about it
which ended up in her being embarrassed
and upset she promised me that she's
never been interested in girls in that
way however she told me that she does
find girls attractive
dude what is the [__] problem I love
this girl and she makes me very happy
this worried me because even though I am
confident young and good-looking male it
made me feel insecure about myself and
feel that I'm not enough for her well
that's very
honest um love the podcast especially
the
vice vid videos as I usually agree with
your outlook on different situations so
just wanted to see what you thought
about my situation should I be concerned
or should I just forget about and
continue to be happy with it thanks to
go [__] yourself well there's a number
of ways that you can go with this you
can either break up with her and then
you're not with her you can uh drive her
to an indulge in this uh attraction and
then get yourself a threesome out of it
but you're probably going to [__] up the
relationship cuz it never [__] works
once you have that open [__] thing
and then we have rules I have to be
there and then eventually you won't be
there and then it'll be [__] weird
and there'll be three people in the room
when you have the breakup talk
um I don't know dude I'm I'm really big
on not like judging people
like you know when it comes to that type
of stuff like the sex stuff and the [__]
that they're [__] into because I
still think we're just scratching the
surface of
um of all the [__] like I don't think we
even understand it at this point so I
think it's perfectly okay if she's into
that type of thing I actually think it's
kind of cool and um no I I I wouldn't I
wouldn't there's no reason to feel in
insecure you know what I mean think
about the porn that you've watched there
you definitely got something in your
sexual [__] closet that she doesn't
[__] know about you know what I
mean something that you're into you're
into like older chick so who the [__]
knows what
right who the [__]
knows I I I think I think
like to really have a great relationship
you kind of you just got to accept the
this that fine line where you have to
know what you're willing to accept and
what you're not willing to accept you
got to know where that line is when
you're young I think you're still
learning that so that's why you're
writing me just figure out where that
line is and if the person's on this side
of that line then you just have to be
totally accepting of them um and once
they know that they can relax and you
have a great [__] relationship you
know um not to toot my own horn but I
have a great relationship with my wife
and uh
and part of it is because we do that
with each other like she you
know she accepts me for the [__]
lunatic that I am and I am a [__]
lunatic
um like I don't it's the weird thing of
me getting with her is I realized how
[__] nuts I am and I don't mean like
hey I'm a crazy guy I like to drink beer
and smoke cigars I mean like there's
something [__] a little off about me
and uh she accepts it she doesn't give a
[__] you know on the surface I'm a great
guy I'm sitting there making pumpkin
bread you know working my ass off
bringing home money but uh the
underneath there like I'm a [__] I'm
a I'm a
lunatic and uh I'm such a psycho that
I'm only just now realizing it and I
can't even I can't even like verbalize
what it is about me that makes me a
[__]
uh I I don't know like I I unbelievably
I don't
know I an antisocial son of a [__] I
will tell you that right now do you know
I'm sitting in a hotel room right now
with a TV that does not get proper
reception on a football Sunday yesterday
I could not get proper reception for the
games and rather and I just shut the TV
off because I'd rather miss the [__]
football games than to call down to the
front desk and have to socially deal
with somebody coming in here and fixing
the TV I just don't want him in here and
while he was fixing the TV I would be
sitting there I talked about this last
night
thinking like what if I just took my
laptop and just smashed him over the
[__] head repeatedly right now you
know I just think [__] like
that I wouldn't do
it but that's what I would be
thinking and the whole time he's helping
me every time he would talk I would just
be in a hostile way thinking shut your
[__]
mouth and that's just one of those ticks
that I have and she accepts me um oh I
didn't read the last bit of the advertis
in here oh by the way thanks to
everybody that came
out
um to the show last night in Fort Wayne
Indiana um looking forward to Cincinnati
going to try to get some [__] ribs
when I'm down there that's what they're
known for um all righty that's the
podcast for this
[Music]
week what's up everybody and welcome
back to the anything better podcast NFL
Edition sponsored by B MGM and we're
going into into week number seven
everybody and uh before we get started
of course we got a shout out the bed
MGM uh sports betting app it's the best
one out there and you guys have been
using it for a while we've been loving
it for a while all you have to do guys
is go to the bmgm app download it and
use the anything better bonus code which
is Burr uh 200 bu
rr200 here's how it works all you got to
do for our promo you put in $10 a
minimum of $10
okay and you place a qualifying bet and
then you will get
$200 guys $200 in bets regardless of the
outcome of your bet so you just got to
put $10 in you get up to 200 please bet
responsibly have fun with it they also
have a Survivor pool still going where
you just pick the team not against the
spread just the team and as long as that
team wins you keep going every week to
get prizes at the end of the season uh
bill and I had a good week we ended up
uh bill I mean steady Eddie over there I
mean Bill's just oh yeah oh Billy win
some lose
some Oh Billy what are you gonna do two
and two I've been two- two every single
week this year except for one where I
went three in one so I am two games
above 500 uh check out my new piano Paul
I got there in the corner you like that
beautiful taking some piano lessons and
we had New England brickmas coming and
do my fireplace you like that ah I love
that dude look at the ston work on that
thing you like that white couch I mean
just I just sort of float around I don't
know why they put that beam in front of
my front door but you know you get what
you pay for
right I'm Sicilian I saw the I saw the
stonework and the white couch right out
of the
gate um yeah I went two and two again
last week so I am I don't even know what
I am we were 20 weeks in so six weeks in
I must be 12 and eight you are two games
above oh okay are you I thought you were
two no not 12 I'm two games above
whatever so I am I am 10 no 14 no you
are uh 14 and 12 no uh I'm 12 and 12 now
no six is 24 yeah oh Paul what am
I divide by two would be 12 and 12 I am
I got it I got it I got it I'm 13 and 11
okay 13 and 11 I am I am 12 and 12 11 13
11 uh all right you sound like you have
[__] throat cancer uh
I uh I went three in one and I am now
even at 12 and 12 after 24 games I had
to crawl myself out of that hole Paulie
heats up this time of year Paulie starts
to see
it there a lot of lot of taking off of
the headset in
September and some heated passionate
conversations with his head coach by
October right around mid October Paul
gets on the same page and things start
[__] clicking hey Bill hey Bill I'm
concentrating
I got it takes a little time Paul you've
been sleeping with your pcks sleeping
with your picks here uh what do you
think about last week well here's dude I
had a buddy of mine took the [__]
Browns had the Browns and the Jets
straight up picking winners that's
impressive having the Browns and jets
especially with the Browns with the
backup quarterback but I'm gonna tell
you something dude now bill you know me
you know I don't mind if my team L I
love you I'll be the I love you too but
I'll be the first to call you up and go
hey we stink hey we lost I gotta tell
you something dude watching the Giants
lose Monday night on a game that not
only did they completely outplay the the
Buffalo Bills the defense shut them out
into the third quarter and then to have
the officials and I know people are
gonna go oh Paul they suck what are you
complaining about they one dude you
can't be in the end zone grabbing the
guy like this holding his arm down and
be upset that you'd have to throw it two
times in a row and that's what happened
got me sick ruined our season if we win
that game and we're two and four we can
salvage a season now we're one and five
and we're in big trouble so that's what
sucked other than that it was an
entertaining entertaining week and I
gotta tell you something I agree with
all that other than you being two and
four and then like you're gonna just
start turning [__] around here no but
two and four going your guy from duke is
[__] home he's sick Hur he's hurt
he's hurt that's what I mean yeah yeah
yeah that's true but look he's got 160
million reasons to be out on that
[__] field way I'm
sitting I love those old guys that say
that oh I feel we back in my day a guy
play with a broken leg it's like all
right hey did construction on the
weekend you know what working out was
when I was a kid you had a second job
you didn't have concussions the guy got
his head hurt he got back in a game it's
like yeah [__] killed himself at the
age of [__] 50 because he wait whoa
Jesus PA you went dark you went dark I'm
sorry um
what did you think of last week Bill uh
I barely watched any of it I had um my
wife came back in town I had come back
in town what did I no no it was my kid
my kid had a week off from school so I
was just like I'm in dad mode I don't
remember what I did I think we went
miniature golfing went AR you you went
to an arcade something right oh yeah no
the arcade was there yeah dude I took uh
I took my daughter and one of her
friends to go play Miniature Golf and
the other girl just was did not like
miniature golf to the point she thought
it was like stupid I I already love this
girl it was so funny she was just
sitting there looking at me I was going
all right go ahead hit the ball you know
with with the with the club and she was
just like I go you know you know hit it
up the thing she did it like one time
and then she was just bored and she was
like every hole she was like walking up
to whatever you were hitting it into
like the windmill seeing if you could go
into it and finally in the fourth hole
I'm like sweetheart you got to hit the
ball and put it in the hole and dude she
just looked at me picked up the ball
walked over to the hole and dropped it
in with her hand and just looked at me
like all right can I go
now oh boy sounds like she's gonna be
trouble no it was exact opposite she at
her young age knew exactly what I knew
golf is [__]
stupid she want to go play arcades
arcade games what do I want to do Paul I
want to go kill some zombies or I want
to sit with this stupid putter for 18
holes hitting into a windmill I already
loved her I loved her even more I was
dying laughing no no that's after that I
was like all right you don't have to
play we're just going to get through
these as quick as we
can yeah yeah I don't mean to I was just
saying I picture her fast forward she's
25 a guy takes her to a restaurant she
see looks around the restaurant rolls
her eyes oh yeah she's not gonna be for
the
week that's what I mean if you're a
dummy that's going to be a quick meal
who gets first picked this week
Bill uh what it's it's uh it's an it's
an odd
week it's an odd week so that would be
I'm odd guy you had first pick this year
so it's week seven so it's
you I love how you you're you trying to
do the math you forgot how to speak
English you go you had first pick this
year it's you you go you get first pick
on odd weeks hey hey Paulie I I I know
when I'm supposed to go all right uh
Paul I'm gonna tell you something right
now I'm not going to do it to you but I
like your Giants getting two and a half
at home against the commanders I I do I
like you at home I like you [__] home
I like that it's a division rivalry I
like that you got [__] last week I like
that the commanders won but you know
something Paul I'm gonna leave that
there for you no hey no no don't talk
don't talk don't talk you owe me
one if there's a week you like the Pats
you got to let me know all right I like
the uh uh I don't know why this game
just stuck out I like the San Diego
superchargers plus five and a half they
had a h breaker again last week but I
just think I don't know KC's a little
erratic division
rivalry uh Travis selfie it's what I
call him now you know now he's getting
all this this stuff here he's out there
he's got this beautiful lady singing
like a bird right and she's sick right
he's sick sick of playing football he's
not sick of [__] snuggling with her
on that little piano bench built too is
he oh no hey write a song about me
running in the flat
Travis
um I'm gonna go with the Chargers
getting five and a half it's a great
pick get your barbecue Paul that's a
great pick because even if they lose
that game it'll be by three I like them
winning that game you know something uh
the Giants were on my I I had a whole
speech about how this was going to be
the first week I take the Giants since
the debacle of week one
and then I thought you were going to
take it from me which you absolutely
could have you absolutely could have but
you were a gentle I wasn't raised that
way and you know something I like the
Patriots getting eight and a half this
week and I'm laying off them so there
you go you can have that you can have
that you can have it I'm not taking it
all right don't what don't that doesn't
count then no no it was doesn't count as
a favor I see what you're trying to do
you're trying to pay you're trying to
pay me back with funny money no no no uh
I'm gonna take the I'm gonna take my New
York football this what half these
[__] things don't even fit what what
am I supposed to do with this huh hey uh
stay off that [__] that's what you that
that's what the what that was the Henry
Hill he came with the guns and the
silencers right there it's turning your
mind into mush he goes I didn't say
anything um I'm gonna take the Giants
getting three at home they got [__]
last week but I really really liked how
the defensive line performed and I like
that Justin Pew came off the couch and
actually gave a little bit of a boost to
our offensive
line Giant getting three against
Washington at home I could that's one I
got to see I'm taking a giant okay I
like the uh I'll tell you a game Paul
game that intrigues me that I just can't
put a [__] finger on here Browns
Colts the line I have is minus three
Browns
uh DeShaun Watson is out though but they
played great last week am I crazy my
information bad I'm going to stay away
from that thing I because I have no idea
with both of those team who's showing up
all right it's like dating an alcoholic
on payday they're going to come
home be happy going straight to the pub
yeah uh I like the uh I'll tell you what
I like Paul oh I'll tell you what I like
I like the uh the Phoenix Cardinals
getting seven and a half in Seattle and
I'll tell you why because I watch that
kid that they have of course I don't
remember his name because I'm an old
fellow um I like their defense and I
really like their quarterback who's in
there for uh the F the [__] guy there
what's his name there uh the the Dunkin
Donuts kid
there who Crispy Cream the guy got the
bet with you that he's gonna balloon up
and get fat the water bug oh oh got the
cool last
name not Kenyan Martin he played for the
New Jersey
Nets uh no Carmelo no no I'm talking
about the [__] quarterback for the
Kyler Murray Kyler Murray Kyler Murray
there you
go thank you I gotta bet with Paul that
at some point in his career he's gonna
have a weight
problem after when the Cardinals have a
good season Paul he's gonna get a little
nuts get a little sideways at a buffalo
white he's got it in the face he's one
of those guys in shape but if you look
at his face you know you'd think he had
a dad bod he's got it in him yeah he
does little Bernard
King Bernard King blew can't got fat oh
dude but he's like 60 something there's
there's a guard in The Legend all right
who do you
got all right so wait who'd you
take who did I just take you took the I
took Arizona Cardinals plus seven and a
half that's plus seven and a half
Seattle like I like that I like that
quarterback I like their defense I like
Gino Smith but I just feel like you know
they sort of sputter they they they they
go and they stop I just don't see them
Bill who you kidding you like the0 five
you know you like the half a point who
doesn't hey Paul you know I'm an ass man
you know you put a little more on the
rear end there I'm gonna [__] look at
[Laughter]
it hey you know what there's something
comforting when you put a little when
you pad the back there's something a
little comforting there is you some
place to rest your arm when you have
your arm around her waist I love that um
dude I am really intrigued about
tonight's game and I usually don't like
taking a Thursday game uh and Trevor
Lawrence is like a maybe to play That's
The Apocalypse Now pick M gun to your
head Paul it's happening
tonight it's happening tonight which is
scary it is it's it's like it's it's in
a couple
hours um Trevor Lawrence likely to play
against the Saints are the Saints for
real I don't know uh the Saints for real
they're [__] erratic my nuts
no they are they are oh boy this this
this is a weird week for me I'm gonna do
it though why not why not Saints no who
you taking I'm taking the [__] cats
I'm taking the Jacksonville Jaguars to
go in there tonight getting two and a
half okay Trevor Lawrence a little
banged up but they're just gonna click
I've said all year that the Lions and
Jags this was their year and so far I'm
going to stick with it I'm going
Thursday night oh Paul's gonna have a w
or a loss in the next few hours uh
Coming Out Swinging this week I like
jumping in the deep end uh let's do it
I'm gonna take the Jags plus two and a
half tonight going in there as dogs all
right okay and I like the Rams at home
minus three against the Steelers I think
the Steelers are another erratic team I
think the Rams are kind of starting to
put it together a little bit they're
both they're both scary teams I just
like that the Rams are at home and and I
think in key positions they're just a
better team and uh the one thing about
the [__] Steelers is all you got to
do is beat him in the first half and
then you have the game because they do
not change their game plan they're like
this is what we're doing this is what
we're doing so I like
uh I like their coach to even if they
have a problem in the first half to come
back and beat him by more than three I'm
taking the Rams at home minus three Paul
minus three buddy minus
three PA you look good you look good
everything all right family's okay
that's great that's great we we gotta
get together we gotta get together
Paulie all right here's what I'm gonna
do you know you just don't call me as
much you know kind of hurts a little bit
but you know it's all right
what
um that [__] neighborhood guilt even
worked on you you're like what yeah I
was like okayy we talked yesterday I
talked hey you know that guy down the
street I mean across the country he made
me feel bad this morning honey don't you
listen to him Paul he's just jealous of
you I'm gonna take a team that every
time I take them they they're always
right there they they W one for me they
made me push
once and and they're playing a bad team
I'm gonna take the um I'm gonna take the
Las Vegas Raiders minus three against
the hapless Chicago Bears who are one
and five and erratic uh and the Raiders
are coming off a by week and they looked
really good that that um on in Prime
Time Devonte Adams is now rested up
after his shoulder I'm going to take
them they're a better I like that
they're a better team I wouldn't say the
Bears are erratic they they're pretty
consistent consistently
erratic hey I got two teams down here
the spreads I don't know who they're
playing who the Eagles got and who do
the Vikings have so the Eagles have um
the Eagles have the Dolphins both teams
are five- one and the Eagles are minus
two and a half at home the Eagles are at
home and who the Vikings playing the
Vikings are playing the 49ers and the
49ers are six and a half Point favorites
that's in
Minnesota I'll take the Vikings I don't
know why why am I gonna take the
Viking I like that 49ers coming off a
[__] loss I think everybody's gonna
bury the 49ers H you know what I'm going
with my gut this week Paul this might be
my first losing week you know what I
mean I don't know what it is I'm just
hanging in there by the way let's talk
about this for a second that's it those
are my picks for this week and now I
hide so you don't see the doubt in my
eyes Bill Burr going into week seven has
not had a losing week ladies and
gentlemen you want to talk about getting
shot out of a cannon into an NFL season
that's pretty impressive my friend
because I because I'm the opposite like
you said I'm either throwing Haymakers
and knocking the guy out or yeah you're
you're Kos Castillo is the fight analogy
I always use yeah it's that or uh Mickey
Ward Gotti any of those classic back and
forth this guy's going to win no this
guy's going to win speaking of that I
gotta give a shout out Sylvester
Stallone's new documentary is coming out
on Netflix it looks
unbelievable what's it
called mean what's it called it's gonna
be right on the first [__] page I
don't know Hollywood
Legend typical me I'm giving it a shout
out I don't know what the name of it is
it's theone I'm sure it's G to pop
up um okay oh did you did you hear
Schwarzenegger on Mark maron's podcast
no oh my God I mean those two have to be
in a movie together oh I heard one thing
where he said I even thought it was
silly he oh dude they it was just they
were complete opposites but they both
are successful so it it's funny so Mark
started the interview and he just said
something going like you know how you
doing how you doing you know I I I know
you you've been going through you've had
some uh you know obstacles or something
like that and he goes what do you mean I
have obstacles why would you start
talking about obstacles rather than my
successes and he goes what kind of
person are you he wasn't insulting him
he was trying to figure him out and Mark
goes I'm an obstacle guy and he all that
works for you and it was just this oh no
dude it was like one of my favorite
comics with one of my favorite uh movie
stars of all time check that shout out
the
WTF um podcast all right
Paul I can't stand [__]
crons uh what about kons what you just
combined Dungeons and kudin I can't
stand
[Laughter]
kudin hey what can I say Polly likes an
appetizer you know what I mean little
surf and turf he takes this word he
sticks it with that word you know hey
you know what I'm
saying
you like the fireplace huh you don't
like the [__] piano Hey listen you
know what you do Mr [__] Manny re
Ramirez what you call him Manny Rivera
Manny Rivera Manny
Rivera Uncle Vinnie's you called My
Cousin Vinny un oh
yeah um last days of Dracula all right
so I got my Interview with the Vampire
that was probably the one that made my
wife laugh the most wait what did you
call it the last days of Dracula oh
but I knew it wasn't that I just knew it
was the uh it was the Dracula movie and
the last days of disco or something was
up um all right I got my fourth and
final you know what movie they [__] up
that should have been amazing I want to
say Mike Myers was in it it was that
Studio 54
movie and for some I never saw it but I
remember people that were involved in it
were not happy with it I'm like oh man H
what a subject matter how do you [__]
that up yeah was a missed opportunity
Paul I'm going to shut up now go ahead
sorry Mike Myers was a [__] so
talented um well he's still alive so I'm
no but I know he's not really he's not
really working he's just kind of
chilling in Toronto but that guy's an
animal hey chilling in Toronto sounds
pretty good Paul a bunch of having like
the Shrek series and Austin power series
Legend of SNL and then you just go chill
in Toronto with your money Paul oh dude
you know I beautiful lakes just north of
that City pul you have no idea what he's
doing right now I love a retired icon
love I love that
statement um all right man you know
what fourth pick is tough this week I'm
seeing what I never see in Paul verie
I'm seeing he's questioning himself I'm
seeing confusion I'm gonna do this dude
because I I believe in this team right
now they're showing me something I'm
gonna take the the the Atlanta Falcons
again I'm gonna take the Atlanta Falcons
again again they're dogs at the Bucks
they had a tough loss they've been in
every game they've lost and um and they
got that absolute Maniac at running back
they have the best running back that
bejan [__] dude that kid is number seven
I'm gonna take them on the road getting
two and a half points um dude that kid
was it beesu he doesn't just fake you
out you do like a face plant no this guy
put together this compilation of just
what he's done this season he's a
combination of like with the moves and
the stopping like Sanders but then the
explosive speed of leanian Tomlinson
he's really I mean listen it's early
he's a rookie like that he's a rookie
but dude he's really good and Baker
Mayfield I don't mean disrespect but
he's Baker Mayfield I saw what he did up
close in personal last year at metti
he's not that great he's won everywhere
he goes and he gets no resp that hurts
me no no no he's he's good but he's not
he's not over the top good and I think
that the Falcons can beat him especially
you talking about his teams or him guy
[__] goes to the Browns gets him to
the playoffs wins a playoff game
nobody's done that in like in like five
presidents and people like yeah you know
[__] he's not bad but he's not I
don't think I'm not afraid of the Bucks
because of him is my point um well
you're not playing either my fourth and
final pick will be the Atlanta Falcons
getting two and a half at the Buccaneers
I'm kind of scared that I have my first
game tonight night now kind of nervous
dude is there anything better than
picking the Thursday night game and just
getting you having a victory right right
in your shirt pocket like somebody stuck
a hundred in there just tipped you hey
Paul have a nice weekend you know got T
we got your table right down front right
down front I get a little daring I get a
little daring when I get 500 I got to
500 I got the you you got you got you
got a lot of Courage I got a little
space I got a little leeway you know
what what what are you gonna do what am
I gonna go 0 and four okay I'll climb
out of that too I did it once I'll do it
again I can't take a [__] hole first
hole I ever
dug you think it's the first ow and four
I've ever done that's what you do Paul
you shoot spider and kill him every
September then you dig the
hole all right we got time it is Bill oh
everybody let the Monday night
special win some money for
you let the Monday night
special withn some [__] money for you
what happened last week did we miss it
again by one [__] hair well here's the
deal Bill we got it uh Christian
McCaffrey has at a touchdown in 15
straight games so I think we gotta ride
that [__]
streak I'm not a Jesus guy but I'll go
with the chrisan go ahead Christian
mcaffry to get a touchdown is is is you
know it's a sure thing as you looking
cool in sunglasses what you do okay uh
oh I do people don't say that a lot
about gingers it's all about covering up
Paul even inside I have the window shade
open so I'm just worried some sun could
get in here the uh the Vikings are
getting oh you already picked the
Vikings so maybe we'll stay away from
the spread I don't give a [__]
Paul that that Paul you know what that
was Paul I was trying not to take us I I
threw that one off my back foot you
wantan you want to go moneyline ners
back across the middle I went Brett Fab
on that one in the fourth quarter dude
if we go moneyline ners that's I'm
guarant
I like I like you're saying that Paul
you better not be selling me [__]
time share here here we go we go money
line ners we go Christian mcaffrey to
get one and
then do we do Kirk Cousins to throw
one to make the odds a little better for
the fans I kind of like that because I
don't think anybody thinks that's going
to happen they like against that 49 def
don't Kurt Cousins scores points Paul
that's what the man does he crushes ass
and he scores [__] points he crushes
ass he's gonna give him the [__]
Juicy Lucy this Monday night right up
there [__] ass Jake uh K Cous I gotta
make a call I'm three minutes late Paul
we gotta wrap this up Jake The Snake
what do you got buddy all right there
you go there you go there it's easy Jake
The Snake said Kirk Cousins is playing
we'll get Kirk Cousins to throw a
touchdown 49ers to win on the money line
and Christian mcaffrey to get anytime
touchdown that's I'll say right now I
ever if I ever had the money to buy into
a pro sports team Paul I'm telling you
right now Jake The Snake is my guy I got
him right in the front office no I told
you Jake The Snake is our Jonah Hill
from
Moneyball the man knows things he has a
quiet
confidence I love it all right well
there you go everybody that's the show
uh you got our picks you got my picks
you got Bill's picks you got the Monday
night special 49ers to win the game
outright Christian McCaffrey to get an
anytime touchdown and uh cousins to
throw a touchdown in the game uh
download the app $10 minimum we'll give
you two they give you $200 regardless of
the outcome of your bet regardless
Freddy s code is Burr 200 Survivor pool
is still available so just pick a team
to win that goes to the end of the year
you'll get prizes and this has been week
uh week preview week number seven let's
go Jaguars tonight oh by the way the
anything better podcast is two games
above 500 two games beat in the book
thanks to steady
and your boy calling out of a hole so
there you go
than what else you want I'm kind of
awesome Paul verie
everybody he digs a hole just to crawl
out of it because he loves The Dramatics
we'll see you next week bet responsibly
don't be a [__] [__] there you
go